I was assuming we would start Today's
Show by talking about the new Republican
Speaker of the House of Representatives
because after all Republicans took over
even though it was by a small margin the
control of the house based on their wins
in the 2022 midterm election November
8th and it was time yesterday for them
to select a new speaker of the house but
no they have not done it and Republicans
are in the midst of what is one of the
biggest humiliating
self-inflicted embarrassments in recent
American political history Republicans
have suffered a true humiliation failing
to elect a speaker of the house after
three rounds of voting the house
ultimately adjourning yesterday without
speaker and they will start again today
and they they're likely already going
right now as you listen to today's
program most Republicans voting for
Kevin McCarthy but not all there is a
faction that has opted not to support
Kevin McCarthy and this actually led to
Hakeem Jeffries on the Democratic side
with Democrats United behind Jeffries
actually coming closer to the 218 votes
that are needed then McCarthy in some of
the votes CNBC has a good nice concise
article about it by Christina Wilkie the
House of Representatives adjourned for
the day Tuesday without a speaker after
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy failed
three consecutive votes to secure enough
support to be selected to the post this
is a historic situation it's an historic
situation some are even saying it's the
first time in a hundred years
that the majority party failed to
coalesce around a candidate to speaker
in this number of votes and we don't
know what the step is the next step is
at this point in time we will get to
that
um after the first ballot resulted in
votes for several Republicans the next
two rounds saw McCarthy's opponents
coalesce around a new Contender
Congressman Jim Jordan of Ohio a
longtime McCarthy Ally Jim Jordan says
he doesn't want it and Lauren Beau bear
and Scott Perry are saying Jim Jordan is
sort of like George Washington George
Washington didn't want to be president
but he did it and they are talking about
Jim Jordan in the same delusional terms
which we will get to a little bit later
what does this mean for the long term of
the Republican party's ability to
I I was going to say govern but it's
like they don't really plan to govern
they govern they plan to investigate
Hunter Biden which we will also get to a
little bit later uh but this is
embarrassing and Tucker Carlson is
saying it's becoming a joke Sean Hannity
is saying that it is becoming a joke and
we don't exactly know the direction this
will ultimately go uh the CNBC article
also
um pointing out during each of the three
voice votes every Democrat rallied
unanimously around incoming minority
leader Hakeem Jeffries a former guest on
on this program by the way but a sect of
conservative Republicans split from
their party to back other candidates
including Jim Jordan as I mentioned in
an unexpected twist McCarthy lost
support as the voting continued which is
just hilarious to see when in the third
round Florida Republican Congressman
Byron Donalds announced his support for
Jordan after voting twice for McCarthy
as a result of Donald's defection
McCarthy got 202 of the 218 votes needed
Jeffries got 212.
um getting uh quite close in fact now is
it likely
that Hakeem Jeffries is going to be the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
it is not likely and there are headlines
saying could Democrats end up with the
speakership I don't believe that it is
likely I believe a more likely scenario
is if Republicans don't move to someone
else that some Democrats end up joining
the majority of Republicans but AOC is
saying that's not going to happen and
that Democrats are going to remain
United so I I think the least likely
scenario is Hakeem Jeffries becomes the
speaker of the house but it's not a zero
chance and man that would be
unbelievable so that's what happened
yesterday I have no news for you about
the next speaker of the house maybe we
will later today but of course everyone
on the Republican side weighing in about
this one of those people
the failed former president Donald Trump
let's talk about that because it's quite
interesting
failed former president Donald Trump
delivered a lie riddled all capital
letters endorsement of sorts of Kevin
McCarthy for speaker of the house now
before we look at Trump's post to truth
social truth
I should tell you kind of the back story
of what was going on
um Kevin McCarthy yesterday failed as I
told you in three votes to secure the
218 votes he needs to become the Speaker
of the House embarrassing humiliating
actually losing support as the votes
went on
yesterday Donald Trump told NBC News
or rather didn't tell NBC news whether
he still supported Kevin McCarthy but
Trump took a little bit of time I guess
to think about it or more likely to be
told what it is that he should say and
this morning he did come out with a
three-post tirade on Troth Central where
again we're interpreting Trump's bizarre
language and syntax I guess he's saying
he supports Kevin McCarthy Trump posting
quote some really good conversations
took place last night I think that means
someone told him what to do but okay
some really good conversations took
place last night and it's now time for
all of our great Republican house
members and here he goes caps lock to
vote for Kevin close the deal take the
victory
and watch crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back
home to a very broken California the
only speaker in U.S history to have lost
the house twice Republicans do not turn
a great Triumph into a giant
embarrassing defeat it's time to
celebrate you deserve it Kevin McCarthy
will do a good job maybe even a great
job just watch now it's important to
mention this has nothing to do with
Nancy Pelosi Trump is obsessed with
Pelosi Pelosi said she is stepping down
from leadership
Democrats don't control the house she's
not asking to be minority leader this
has nothing to do with Pelosi but Trump
is obsessed with Pelosi and by the way
it's funny he says McCarthy will do a
good job maybe it'll even be great I
don't know not exactly a ringing
endorsement Trump then adding also on
Truth Central quote if Republicans are
going to fight
we ought to be fighting Mitch McConnell
and his domineering china-loving boss I
mean wife Coco Chao Trump continuing
with the racial epithets or as some
wrongly call them epitaphs which is a
completely different thing the harm they
have done to the Republican party is
incalculable today he couldn't be
elected dog catcher in Kentucky sadly he
only won because of my endorsement went
up 21 points sorry and then lastly Trump
going back to caps lock take the Victory
and run says Donald Trump trump waited
to decide does he stick with Kevin
McCarthy or not apparently he decided
yes he sticks with him but Falling a
little bit short of a full-throated
ringing endorsement we saw others last
night
seemingly taking baby steps away from
Kevin McCarthy this includes
propaganda stuck or Carlson this
includes propaganda Sean Hannity and
others that we will get to after this
short break remember next Wednesday
January 11th 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific
we will be doing the first viewer Town
Hall of 2023. I hope that you will join
us live everyone is invited to call in
our members will get Priority Access to
talk to me you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and remember always
remember
subscribe to the YouTube channel folks
three million of you watched our Clips
last month and did not subscribe hit
that subscribe button help us get to 2
million
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right let's continue looking and
listening to the sights and sounds
yesterday at the House of
Representatives surrounding this
humiliating embarrassment for
Republicans wherein they failed after
three votes to elect the speaker of the
house so many interesting things going
on and I want to start with multiple
Republicans likening Jim Jordan to
George Washington and and I'm not
talking about you know maybe you think
oh is that like my neighbor George no
we're talking about the first president
of the United States they're comparing
Jim Jordan to George Washington and
acting as if there is a similarity I can
assure you George Washington would not
have looked the other way about alleged
wrongdoing in the wrestling locker room
the way Jim Jordan is accused of doing
but let's put that aside for a moment
congresswoman Lauren bobert is one of
the folks who is defecting seemingly
from supporting Kevin McCarthy for
speaker of the house she appeared on
where is this a Sean Spicer's show on
Newsmax and she said you know George
Washington did not want to be president
but he did it because it was right
and it's similar
to Jim Jordan uh listen to this there's
uh many people who we could propose I I
am a big proponent of Lee zeldin who
actually won US the majority Jim Banks
is wonderful Kevin Hearn it would be an
amazing speaker an amazing leader Mike
Johnson it could be another option
um but also going back to Jim Jordan
George Washington did not want to be
president of the United States but he
did what was right for his country
uh you know another similarity George
Washington never told the lie and
neither did Jim Jordan except when he
lied four times about did you speak to
Trump on the day of the riots or not
um hard to imagine a more different
individual than George Washington
uh than Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan and this is the result quite
frankly like I know it's just nonsense
that just funnels right out spews out of
Lauren bobert's mouth and we could say
David the analysis can stop there we
don't need to go any further but to some
degree this sort of stuff is the result
of teaching whatever version of History
these Republicans want to be teaching in
school you end up thinking a sketchy
wrestling coach turned congressman who
yells at every interview is in any way
like the first president of the United
States George Washington now it's also
possible that bobert is mentioning
George Washington because she doesn't
know any the other historical figures
always a possibility with someone as
ignorant as bobert but bobert is not the
only one
who is making this George Washington
comparison Scott Perry who is Republican
elect Congressman uh elect uh from
Pennsylvania he went on Fox News and he
also said you know George Washington Jim
Jordan there's really something there
well if you listen to watch the speech
that Jim Jordan gave yeah quite honestly
most Republicans sat there and said oh
my goodness why isn't this guy running
for speaker and while I know Jim would
be reluctant I remind everybody George
Washington was reluctant to when his
country called so a reluctant hero maybe
not the hero they wanted to be
but the hero that their country demanded
that they be
that's very stupid extremely extremely
stupid and here is Lauren bobert later
appearing on Fox News
Brett Bayer mentions you know I think
it's possible Jim Jordan not only isn't
running for the job but doesn't want the
job and bobert goes he may have to do it
he may have to do it and if you heard
from him that he does not want it in any
way shape or form
what do you say I have heard that from
him and uh if we have the numbers then
sorry Jim Jordan we're going to make you
do what's right for the country we love
you now of course it would be very wrong
if Jim Jordan being speaker of the house
is right then I don't know right and
wrong anymore and I know many in my
audience already believe that and they
write to me all the time saying I have
no moral compass but I'm not really
addressing that uh I do not believe Jim
Jordan is going to be the speaker of the
house and in fact if we pull up and I
apologize
um I wanted to find this earlier and I
forgot speaker of the house if we look
at the betting markets on speaker of the
house and let's see there's actually two
different ones here that we can look at
um okay if you look at oh this is old
action I don't have the numbers okay
folks I apologize we if they don't
resolve who the speaker is after today's
votes one of the elements that I will
prepare for you tomorrow I my lack of
professionalism is showing I will
prepare for you tomorrow the betting
markets on who will ultimately be the
Speaker of the House let's now talk
about the fox propaganda machine and
their reaction to this Republican
humiliation
how did Tucker Carlson respond to the
failure Yesterday by Republicans to
select a speaker of the house how did
Sean Hannity react to that very same
failure well let's take a look Tucker
Carlson weighed in last night and his
suggestion was McCarthy's not really
conservative anyway maybe suggesting
he's not really the right guy for the
job let's take a listen McCarthy is not
conservative enough to represent a party
that's just taken back the house from
Nancy Pelosi and they are definitely
right about that McCarthy is not
especially conservative he's in fact
ideologically agnostic he's flexible his
real constituency is the lobbying
community in Washington now Tucker
Carlson is not wrong but he also is
wrong as is often the case with people
like Tucker Carlson it's absolutely true
that when I think of Kevin McCarthy I
don't think small government
conservative who
cherishes and prioritizes and puts on a
pedestal the values that we would think
of 30 years ago of Republican
conservatism he's nothing like Reagan
for example and believe me I don't agree
with any of those ideas but he's not
even in that mold McCarthy is a scheming
opportunist with delusions of grandeur
and a sick addiction to being adjacent
to power
that's what I think of when I think of
McCarthy and that's the way he operated
during the Trump Administration until it
became untenable
uh and that's the way that he is
operating now so in that sense Tucker is
correct
on the other hand it's also not really
true that he is the epitome of the I'll
just do whatever the lobbyists want me
to do I mean to some degree that's true
but in the sense that it's true of most
of the members of Congress he is a guy
who sought an opportunity here to maybe
slide in to be Speaker of the House it
may work at the end of the day but it's
going to depend on the direction of this
group of 15 to 20 anti-mccartheides in
the Republican party which we will see
so to a little bit Tucker is right but
he's also misstating the big picture of
Kevin McCarthy which is he's just
thirsty for power and wants to be
adjacent to whoever is most powerful at
the time that's what got him to sort of
go with Trump for a while
until he got caught making anti-trump
comments then we go to Hannity Hannity
straight up says Republicans are about
to make themselves a total clown show
listen to this new year with the Fox
News Alert it is day one of the
188th Congress and House Republicans now
are on the verge of becoming a total
clown show if they're not careful but
despite the cheering and Elation from
Democrats and the mob and the media it's
not a dire situation yet yeah so Hannity
isn't necessarily abandoning McCarthy
but he is sounding the alarm and he's
done this before remember sounding the
alarm that this might end up with
Republicans looking really stupid or I
guess more stupid than they already do
Hannity's instinct is protecting the
image of the Republican party and you
might remember that in the text messages
that we obtained from Hannity
in the immediate aftermath and as the
Trump riots were going on
he recognized the way that it looked he
recognized how terrible terrible
terrible terrible it looked for
republicans and for Trump what was going
on on January 6th and he was texting I
think it was Meadows and maybe Kaylee
maganany and uh some others and he
certainly had a more or less on this
planet assessment of how terrible it
looked and aside from whether he likes
Kevin McCarthy or not and I think he's
probably fine with McCarthy one way or
the other uh he is saying this could end
up making us look really really bad
let's see what happens today by the time
you listen to Today's Show we may know
who the speaker is or it may go another
day which would be truly incredible
we'll follow up George Santos may be one
of the biggest Liars in the 2024 2023 uh
Republic did I say 2025 I'm now thinking
I might have earlier in the show said it
was 2024. did I do that I don't know why
I just had a flashback
2023 Congress that is now taking power
George Santos had a really wacky wacky
day yesterday on Capitol Hill as a
reminder George Santos is the
republican-elect uh congressman-elect
becoming Congressman now presumably from
representing New York who lied about his
employment history he lied about his
educational history he lied about his uh
Jewish background which seems to be
imaginary he's under U.S criminal
investigation Brazil is criminally
investigating him
etc etc he had quite a day in Washington
DC you've got to see this stuff first in
an effort to avoid having to talk to any
media he just kind of did this thing
where he walks quickly and tries to get
away from reporters he ended up walking
into the dead end of a basement hallway
in the Longworth House Office Building
while trying to get away from reporters
you've got to see this stuff
Mr Santos do you intend to serve both
years of your term
not taking any questions by the way tell
us if you plan to serve both years of
your term Mr Santos
will you answer any question besides
will you support leader McCarthy to be
speaker
coffee can you speak to any of the
concerns about your biography about what
you've told folks about your background
oh my God
probably the leadership told you
anything Mr Santos
so hitting a dead end there and having
to turn around and then it gets even
more Awkward
um uh laylee ibsa tried asking him some
questions when he first showed up
yesterday he also didn't want to answer
those they're constituents
do you feel like you're qualified to
serve in this Congress right now
by the way the backpack I know
I
know
what's your response to calls for a
house after investigation
do you have any statements about your
campaign and how you hope to govern
now
the mirror I I love the question this
guy's not going to govern are you nuts
that it's it's a funny question in that
he's obviously not going to do any
governing hope to carry out your full
term
what can you say to reassure your
constituents so you'll do what you said
you're going to do on your campaign
all right you get the point walking
miles seemingly avoiding questions from
reporters I don't know how tenable it's
going to be for him to just never answer
questions then we get to him sitting in
the house chamber and you almost start
to feel bad for him except that you
don't
um as proceedings were going on just
sitting by himself on his phone and we
have video of it right now that we're
showing you sitting uh by himself
looking dejected sulking in the house
chamber
um on his phone and just nobody talking
to him you let me know whether you feel
bad I mean listen he he lied about
everything you know this guy really
really did lie about everything and now
I mean listen it's not like Republicans
are honest it's not like I have a
delusion that the reason Republicans are
shunning him is because they're honest
and this guy is dishonest obviously
that's not the case uh but it is just
funny and kind of like weird to see
um there he is picking his nose and
we'll actually look at that moment a
little more closely that was a much
scrutinized moment almost like the
Zapruder film uh you will see here that
he does an interesting move as he sits
there where he goes in for the pick
and then very casually does a sort of
rolling motion does a kind of a rolling
motion and he does seem to be able to
dislodge the mucus that he was able to
obtain there and then lastly when this
was all said and done George Santos
attempting to leave the capital again
sort of disoriented and not taking any
questions from Caitlin way Burns special
description from CBS News can you tell
us how your first day was
Congressman Santos
he really does look like a lost kid on
the first day of camp with the backpack
and everything and just it's it's
bizarre imagery
it's like how the hell do I get out of
here
you tell us how your first day was no
well nobody talked to me and the kids
were mean do you have anything to say
about all of the allegations
against you
are you confident that you'll be sworn
in yes
and off he goes into the Dark Knight
ultimately finding an elevator that
would eventually take him outside this
doesn't seem at all sustainable and one
would imagine at some point if George
Santos is actually going to serve he's
going to have to answer questions from
someone and they're gonna have to be
real questions not like those softball
interviews that we looked at last week
so a tough first day at school at work
sorry for George Santos unclear whether
he had those Capri Sun juice pouches in
his backpack or what but not going well
and we will see what happens today
nothing definitive by the way
as to whether there was any kind of quid
pro quo between Santos and Kevin
McCarthy the of course speculated quid
pro quo would be McCarthy supports
Santos not resigning and being sworn in
Santos pledges to vote for McCarthy for
speaker of the house and all day amidst
all those questions the one thing that
McCarthy rather that Santos did answer
is that yes he will be supporting Kevin
McCarthy for speaker if you've just been
listening today and you're curious about
the visual component for these things
I've played check them out on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and of course we'll
also have all of these clips on our
YouTube channel make sure you were
subscribed to the big very big YouTube
channel youtube.com the David Pacman
show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to be speaking with Rachel
Bernstein who's an educator therapist
author media and government consultant
and also host of the weekly podcast
indoctrination and for over 30 years has
been treating former cult members and
their families victims of malignant
narcissists former supremacists
conspiracy theorists quite quite a list
uh Rachel I appreciate you joining me
today oh it's my pleasure thanks for
asking me to be on so I mean before we
get into some of the nitty-gritty how
did it happen that you started I don't
know if you would necessarily call it a
focus but that that you started working
in this particular space with these
types of folks right yeah it is most
definitely a focus and it has remained
so there was someone in my family who
got ensnared in a particular cultic
group so it was kind of dinner table
conversation and then when I went off to
college I had already learned about some
Cults that use front names on college
campuses to get people off of college
campuses and to kind of just take them
away and I saw them with my own eyes and
you know first when you hear about
culture thinking someone's being a
little paranoid and maybe they're
exaggerating and there it was and then
when I went on to become a therapist I
was noticing that there were a lot of
people who just didn't think they
existed and I thought I need to be a
resource I need to be able to be out
there to help people when they have had
this issue because it's very specific
when we talk about
cults for example to start with there
are dramatically different scenarios
when someone has already left the cult
and the support that they might need at
that point versus if someone is in the
cult and loved ones may be thinking more
of what is sometimes colloquially known
as an intervention can you talk about
whether you deal with both or more the
after the fact only
right so most of what I deal with is the
after the fact although I am involved in
some interventions these are
non-forcible conversational style
interventions it's important that people
know that so that they don't get afraid
of them that it's not at all that you're
you know pulling up in a van and putting
someone in something that's windowless
and taking them away yeah it really is
helping to educate them about what they
are involved in because people involved
in cults actually know the least about
them they have the least amount of
access to the information so all you're
doing is informing them about what's
true but I'd say about 70 of the people
I work with have been out sometimes for
a few days I mean I've had people show
up in my office as they left that day
um and others who have been out for
years and realize that they need help
because there are so many triggers that
have been implanted that they didn't
realize until they got triggered when
I've interviewed former white
supremacists for example one of the
trends is that when they reflect on how
they were originally sucked in they they
all tell a very similar story and it
doesn't mean it's the only story but at
least the ones I've spoken to have a
similar story which is sort of
opportunity caused by usually problems
at home often with absent parents or
abusive parents a sort of search for
meaning and inclusion from some kind of
group so sometimes there was bullying at
school it's it's sort of a
circumstantial in terms of the
environment that they're in that makes
them vulnerable to the recruitment of
some of these supremacists is that your
experience and also is it similar with
the people that get sucked into Cults
that may not be extremist in that same
way
right so that has been my experience as
well in addition to there is a timing
Factor so when people ask me what kind
of person gets involved in a cult
sometimes it is exactly that that
they're looking for something they're
looking for meaning they're looking for
connection Community for having a
purpose they're trying to find some
space for them in the world maybe in
kind of parallel universe because they
haven't found their way in mainstream
Society but
for a lot of people it's a timing issue
they are away from home for the first
time or they just went through a trauma
or they were just diagnosed with
something or they were just abused for
the first time and they're looking to
escape that so I think a lot of factors
actually play into it you've worked with
the FBI on some cases that maybe some in
our audience are are familiar with one
such case is the Branch Davidians in
Waco Texas and the negotiations that
took place there can you talk a little
bit about
what is such a negotiation process like
what are the what are the principles
that are at play in such negotiations in
those situations
you know those are interesting times
certainly
um because there is something very
incendiary about the moment and so
you're kind of trying to beat the clock
what you find when you're dealing with
the FBI are really any kind of
government agency is that you're trying
to educate them about what's different
about this and how they need to interact
in a different way than they might be
thinking that doesn't always happen they
don't always listen unfortunately
um and but you can give your idea about
how to make sure that they don't make
people afraid of leaving by doing what
they're doing to get them to come out
I've been involved in a number of raids
not planning them necessarily but
helping with the aftermath and helping
with people who have been taken off
compounds with the Branch Davidians I
use the information that I knew about
what would make people scared of leaving
and to and I think to really make them
feel scared of the world which is what
unfortunately the ATF did
um by playing very loud music and making
them really feel overwhelmed and by kind
of proving the cult leader right about
the world unfortunately
um that then they stayed in but the
other information I used was from people
who had escaped before the fire
some of the families the parents the
children who had been able to get out
who were also guiding me about what they
thought would be the best sort of course
of action for the people still in it
sometimes they listen again and
sometimes not so much so you mentioned
you mentioned the the leaders
depending on which of which cult one is
talking about or extremist group
oftentimes the followers allow or maybe
accept is the better word
that their leaders play by a different
set of rules there's rules for the
followers and the leaders often don't
follow those very same rules now in
cases like maybe a Jim Jones and the
people's Temple it's he seems sort of
like as a deity almost and so that makes
it really easy to understand well like
if you're God or Godlike of course you
have a different set of rules that you
play by then we the followers play by
but not all of these Cults have leaders
that necessarily frame themselves in
this kind of deified way
in the non-overtly deifying Cults what
are the explanations or justifications
that the followers have for why the
rules they have to follow aren't the
rules that the leader has to follow
it's a great question uh it happens time
and time again and to make this very
relatable this is something that also
happens in relationships with
controllers and with malignant
narcissists where they can do whatever
they want and you can't question them
and they can have access to your
information or your passwords or your
you know ATM and they they can gain
everything and you have nothing you have
no power you can't get any of their
information but they can get all of
yours so it happens in these sort of
one-on-one these sort of dyad Cults too
within these relationships but going
back to the idea of Carlton why
permission is given
permission is given for everything when
it comes to the leader within a cult
um and that's actually why some people
start Cults because they love that they
love having the freedom to do or say
whatever they want and they love knowing
that the rules only apply to the
followers I mean it's sort of you know
the sociopath or the narcissistic
playground
um and you know they couldn't enjoy it
more unfortunately what happens when you
get involved in a system like this
is that there's kind of what I see is a
dual track of influence one is overt and
one is covert and the overt is here are
the teachings here's what we believe in
and here's what you need to do to be a
good follower the covert one is if you
question how things are run you will not
receive the benefit of this all of your
sacrifice will be for naught right your
time is going to be wasted if you are
questioning the fact that I have
44 rolls royces like with rajneesh and
you get nothing and you sleep on the
floor then that negativity is going to
get in the way of you receiving what I'm
trying to give you and you need to
question yourself people learn how to
turn the focus inward within a cult and
they question themselves for doubting
and doubting and being negative being
angry about anything or resenting
anything in occult is considered really
really awful and it's going to be
counterproductive to what you're trying
to get by being there so you think
you're working against Yourself by
having critical thinking it's a
fascinating kind of way of getting into
gaslighting when I've spoken to experts
on conspiracy theories sometimes the
idea comes up of like more destructive
or dangerous conspiracy theories versus
one ones that are sort of like more
benign and sometimes there will be this
contrast where it's like you know some
of the anti-semitic conspiracy theories
that lead people to seek out and do
violence against Jewish people very
dangerous on the other hand believing
the Earth is flat not so dangerous and
to some degree every conspiracy theory
expert that I talked to says yes in the
overt sense it's true that one is much
more dangerous than the other at the
same time rarely is there only one
conspiratorial belief these things open
doors to more and more extreme beliefs
and so we should be careful to say this
one is totally benign we don't need to
worry about it when we think about that
as applied to Cults are there what we
might call not very dangerous cults like
for example I read an article not long
ago about how CrossFit or like Peloton
or Soul cycle they have a lot of the
elements on paper of a cult but it's not
really dangerous in the way that a lot
of these others are can you talk a
little bit about that and kind of
categorizing these
right so yeah there are some cultic
groups that are more dangerous than
others and undoubtedly and it all
depends upon the leader it depends where
the leader wants to take it and what the
leader needs in terms of ego
aggrandizement if they want to just test
you to see what you're willing to do for
them because it makes them feel powerful
then they will sometimes push you to the
brink they'll push you to the point
where it's not healthy for you it's
actually dangerous for you just because
they want to see you struggling because
they told you to
um and I think that when you're dealing
with Cults that are dangerous
you're dealing with Cults where they
will tell you for example look a lot of
the ones that deal with pseudoscience
where here we have a cure for you so
people bypass actual cures things that
could really help them in order to get
what the cult leader or that person is
telling them they need and they end up
not doing well or they end up not living
but they've already signed their rights
away and so there's nothing that they
can do about it and so yes when you're
engaging in anything that feels like
someone's giving you the Cure
it can be potentially very very
dangerous and there can be a lot of
medical neglect actually in those
situations the other is when people are
finding themselves getting more
militaristic and they're talking about
the end times and they're talking about
survival that's when you get into a lot
more of the stockpiling of weapons of
also needing to see the world and the
people in it as less than as not human
anymore and that you're above them when
you have that polarization then you have
a lot of danger last thing generally
that I want to talk about and there's a
lot here is get getting people out right
we know when it comes to false beliefs
generally
beating people over the head with facts
doesn't really work very well you know
we've had dozens of guests where we talk
about that in in one way shape or form
empathy is good understanding is good
communicating that the person's not
going to be shamed if they decide oh you
know what I was wrong about this thing I
want to get out making clear that
they're going to have you know the
resources if with scientologists that's
the big thing where they have nothing
and so part of staying in is I'm going
to have literally nothing if I get out
of here
um in terms of the getting out you
mentioned sometimes the people in The
Cult know the least about the cult I
don't necessarily need to one thing I
sometimes think about is in
conversations with Mormons and there's
different opinions about whether
Mormonism is a cult but let's at least
consider the possibility it might be
cult like many Mormons don't know that
Joseph Smith each time he read the gold
tablets or whatever they are it was a
different reading and he had a history
of being a con man and all these
different things they just don't know
that and and simply telling them that
that's a reality is not going to be
convincing if you just kind of give them
that information so what are the right
ways to communicate the information that
they might be lacking because we know
just like hey here's a bunch of stuff
about your beliefs doesn't really work
right I'm so glad you asked this
question because this is most of the
work that I do helping to have the
conversation that's difficult to have
with someone who might not be ready to
look at the fact that they were involved
in a cult and also helping guide
families and friends and spouses to know
how to have these conversations so as
not to kind of you know push them
farther back in and make them feel
alienated judged Etc right so one of the
things you want to be able to do is you
want to engage them in a conversation
about what they liked about it let them
know that you're going to be fair-minded
about this that there must have been a
reason that they got involved what was
the promise what did they think they
could get and maybe who did they meet
who they liked Etc so that you're not
just going in for the kill you're not
just going into talk about what was bad
because if you do then they're going to
feel foolish they're going to feel like
if it was all bad why did I get involved
why did I stay yeah so talk about what
they got or really talk about what they
were promised that they probably still
didn't get because there's always the
carrot that's dangled
so you get a sense of sort of what they
were searching for what is part of their
value system what they wanted to cure in
the world what they wanted to cure about
themselves
and then let them know that you have
information
and let them know that they can listen
to it or not they can disagree with it
or not but that this is information you
want to give to them out of respect for
them that this was something that was
kept from them but people should have
access to information so they can make a
fully informed decision and you let them
know that if they feel like they want to
go back they can go back
um there there have been plenty of times
that I've done an intervention where the
person has gone back but because I said
listen I'm glad you're saying that
you're not involved in a cult just in
case let me just give you a rundown of
what a cult is yeah and what happens
there and they could disagree with me in
the moment but they went back
it's like I planted a seed they went
back and they saw these things for
themselves so they could come out on
their own terms and so if the person
doesn't feel judged if they really are
able to maintain the sense that you see
them as capable you see them as bright
you see them as people who are not just
gullible people then you are going to be
able to have a much more successful
conversation and then say I have
information you can also share me and
share information with me about your
group and I will share information about
it too that I've heard so that there
really is a reciprocity to the
conversation
super interesting we've been speaking
with Rachel Bernstein who's an educator
therapist and author she also hosts the
weekly podcast indoctrination Rachel
really a pleasure having you on I
appreciate your time thank you so much
for having me on good to talk to you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right we've spoken a little bit
before about the Brewing war between
Maga uh suck UPS Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert both are Republican
members of the House of Representatives
both were re-elected in 2022 Marjorie
Taylor green by an easy margin Lauren
bobert by the slimmest slimmest slimmest
of margins and increasingly they are at
odds with each other we started seeing
this a couple of weeks ago and I talked
to you about it and now they are
increasingly uh going after each other
in an ugly way which I think we should
support now there are people online
talking about you know cat fight and
sort of uh all this this sort of stuff
that is really not interesting to me the
fact that they are both women
um to me is is not part of why this is
interesting if Madison cawthorne were
still in Congress and he was the one at
odds with bobert or green we would be
just as interested the interesting part
is these cartoonish vapid ignorant do
nothing Maga people
arguing with each other is interesting
because all they really have is their
allegiance to Maga
that's I mean listen if it weren't for
Trump and if it weren't for Maga as
something that they could say we support
they never would have been elected in
the first place and so it's interesting
as we see Trump's 2024 campaign get off
to a shaky start to say the least and we
see questions as to whether or not Maga
will eventually acquiesce and get Kevin
McCarthy elected speaker of the house
it's particularly interesting to see
Maga subdivide and I'm going to go to a
video yesterday we looked at some of
this interview earlier this is the
interview during which Lauren bobert on
Fox News uh told Brett Bayer just like
with George Washington
if we decide Jim Jordan needs to be the
speaker then he will be the speaker she
was presented with some of the things
that Marjorie Taylor green said about
her she then goes after Marjorie Taylor
green it's getting very ugly and Maga
seems to be subdividing let's take a
look you sound bus Marjorie Taylor green
and then Dan Crenshaw Nicholas please
bobert under two million dollars for
money to get elected and then there's a
few of them that don't want to support
him as Speaker
some of the reasons that these people
have for not voting for McCarthy are
unbelievably Petty unbelievably Petty
this is about Showmanship this is about
notoriety it has nothing to do with the
conservative by the way the irony of Dan
Crenshaw saying others are being petty
is not lost on me but it's I don't want
to get derailed because this is more
about Lauren bobert's response which
we're going to see here in a moment
agenda Marjorie Taylor green uh
congresswoman saying that you know you
just want a very close election in
Colorado uh and that went to a recount
and she's saying that Kevin McCarthy
helps you get across the Finish Line uh
and that you're just trying to make a
point or make a splash how do you
respond to that well there are laws in
this building that prevent me from going
too far into detail but I can say that I
did not receive any help in that
election and that was a very big deal we
pay dues as members to the nrcc and they
were nowhere to be found and then as far
as
our request being petty I don't think a
secure border is petty I don't think a
term limits bill being brought to the
floor not demanded to pass but brought
to the floor so we actually have an
option to vote on that is petty you're
not saying that your other colleagues
you're not saying your other colleagues
don't want a secure border or don't want
a balanced budget right you're not
saying that about your Republican
colleagues we haven't seen that
demonstrated from leadership we asked
for the RSC the Republican study
committees budget all right you get the
point Lauren bobert saying Marjorie
Taylor green is straight up lying
straight just making it up whole cloth
the support that she received what is
the future of this intramaga spat or
fight I don't have the answer but one of
the things that I expect to happen is As
Trump and if Trump and Maga continue to
look weaker and weaker and part of how
we know this is how are Trump's primary
polls looking including against people
like Ron DeSantis who haven't even
declared that they're running for
anything if Trump looks injured
irreparably I think maybe is the term we
would apply to it I think you will see
more Maga infighting because they will
realize the Trump train the Maga train
on which we even came to power is no
longer going to be the buoy that keeps
us afloat if the allegiance to Maga is
no longer the buoy that keeps us afloat
what else do we need to or can we do to
separate and distinguish ourselves from
the other people who came to power on
the same nothing that we came to power
which was Trump was popular enough at
the time that by endorsing us and us
saying we love Trump we were able to win
if Trump
surges in the polls and re-establishes
himself as the clear guy who's on his
path to win the 2024 Republican
nomination I believe you will see less
of this infighting it is a reflection of
the shakiness and the crumbling nature
of the Trump Maga movement at this point
in time there's a very interesting
article in salon by Amanda Marcotte
about what we are about to see
Republicans do Republicans that who are
right as we speak
coming to power taking control of the
house and I guess selecting a speaker of
the house although it's been harder to
actually get that done the article is
called the GOP is about to go wild with
phony Biden investigations the media
must not take the bait Republicans know
how to manipulate the both sides impult
of the press Hunter Biden's laptop is
not a story writes Amanda Marcotte this
is an important
um uh admonishment that I hope is being
made in corporate media newsrooms around
the country although I fear that it is
not
the both sides narrative is a toxic form
of false equivalence that has
unfortunately become really common in
corporate media and there's a couple of
reasons why and this is the idea that
all political viewpoints are equally
valid and deserve to be heard regardless
of their factual basis regardless of
their uh connection to reality it's
intellectually lazy it undermines
critical thinking it undermines rational
discourse and those are elements that
are essential to a functioning democracy
why does corporate media do this why
does corporate media have to use one
example
one person who says here's the climate
science and one person who just denies
it it's 50 50 on your screen I mean look
I see this talking head saying here's
the climate science and I see this
talking head saying you can't believe
any of that stuff they're getting 50 50
representation even though in the
empirical Community one side has more
than 99 agreement of the scientific
Community behind them why does corporate
media do that there's two main reasons
number one
they do it because they want to avoid
being called biased
to some degree they say well listen it's
controversial so let's represent these
two things 50 50 even if in reality they
are not 50 50. that's one reason the
other is for Ratings it's much more
interesting to do these debates where
you actually foment the belief
in things for which there is no factual
basis when the media fall for this trap
they give credibility to lies and
misinformation and they perpetuate those
ideas they perpetuate also the idea that
there's not really an objective Truth
Listen let's have a debate as to what
the tax rate should be okay well that's
a debate there are moral questions
economic questions fairness questions
governance questions fine let's have a
debate as to whether climate change is
real
totally different thing irresponsible uh
and and by the way I'm fine with
discussions among people who disagree
about the climate science I think that
that's fine the problem is that
corporate media that does 39 minutes of
content per hour or less the rest is
commercials and hosts four minute
debates where half the debate is a
climate science denier that's a
different thing that we're talking about
and it's especially dangerous in the
current political climate where we see
the rise in authoritarianism we see a
decline in trust in institutions it's
important for the media to hold
politicians accountable it's important
for the media to hold public figures and
so-called experts accountable for their
words and their actions but you've got
to do so in a way that at least somewhat
aligns with reality it doesn't mean you
give equal weight and time
to baseless conspiracy theories and
propaganda and that's where we get to
Joe Biden the Biden crime family 100
essential I accidentally hit the truth
Central button because I'm so so wound
up what we what we have to see here is a
recognition that the hunter Biden
conspiracy theory is the prototypical
example of how the both sides narrative
can end up just being so destructive
it's been thoroughly debunked it's been
fact-checked they insist on baseless
elements of Hunter Biden's background at
some point the media has a
responsibility to report what the facts
are not to promote baseless conspiracy
theories to give equal weight to lies in
propaganda to host false debates which
is what they are at the end of the day
and
to the extent that Republicans are going
to be obsessing for two years about
impeach Biden for these crimes those
crimes Hunter Biden this that the other
thing
if corporate media is going to cover
that they should just be clear there's
no credible evidence to support the
things that people like Marjorie Taylor
green want to investigate about Joe and
Hunter Biden will they do it probably
not we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P
here's a voicemail from a conspiracy
theorist who goes by the name total
control this is an exercise in caution
this is what can happen when your brain
is on conspiracy theories
hey Dave it's me total control871 I know
it's been a while right yeah I didn't
want all of 2022 to slip by without you
knowing that I'm still alive I know I
know you're just killing yourself right
now right
but I I still have the same question I
think the last time I called and put on
your voicemail
why am I still alive
I never take a single injection I never
use a face diaper I never socially
distance and yet I keep on living just
fine
not even a head cold wow
and nobody around me is getting sick
either
so hey Dave I'm just calling to find out
how come well I guess this will make the
is this the Third
prediction of severe winter of illness
and death and we're up to Triple dimmick
now right first it was twendemic now
it's triple demic you know it's
interesting just speak it's sort of like
I don't know they keep talking about car
accidents but I've been driving for 20
years and I'm alive so there must really
be nobody dying in car accident it's
very very dumb What's it gonna be
gonna beat winter quadruple damic I
don't know what am I
okay nobody can never keep it straight
because you know it's
um evolving with the rolling of the eyes
but anyway I'm still here I'm still
kicking all right well total control
hasn't died and he wants us to know that
despite uh despite not being vaccinated
and of course that is the very very
scary Mind of a conspiracy theorist for
lack of a better term we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah we're going
to make money on the bonus show today
with the following topics we are going
to talk about House Republicans taking
as one of their first actions yesterday
removing the metal detectors from the
house floor okay we'll talk about what
they're doing tobacco companies in Spain
are being billed for the cleanup of
cigarette butts this is very interesting
and we will also talk about the number
of children in the United States who
accidentally ate cannabis Edibles in
2020 and does this vindicate the claims
of the anti-cannabis right wing
and it does not we will talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get access instantly not in
an hour not in a day get access
instantly by signing up at
joinpakman.com